si en efecto esa es una de las
incógnitas en esta elección el voto
indígena el que fue de asia aia cv pérez
que tuvo una votación sorprendente
porque ningún candidato indígena había
logrado un porcentaje tan alto
prácticamente el 19 por ciento
de lo que se puede observar hasta este
momento ese voto se dividiría en tres
partes una iría al voto nulo que es el
que el propio ex candidato ya q pérez ha
convocado la otra que es ese sería un
tercio del voto más o menos que puede
hablar hacia el el otro tercio iría
hacia el candidato guillermo lasso y el
otro tercio se dividiría entre el voto
nulo que es el que perdona foto a andré
zarautz
boto digamos en blanco que no se cuenta
tampoco igual que el nulo es decir se
dividiría en tres tercios prácticamente
de lo que se ha visto hasta este momento
hubo un llamado de uno de los dirigentes
indígenas del señor jaime vargas
para apoyar al candidato de rafael
correa entre zarautz pero fue
inmediatamente desautorizado por el
resto de la dirigencia indígena entonces
hay un como decía al inicio hay una
incógnita sobre este voto ahora profesor
quién ganará las elecciones según las
firmas encuestadoras de su país que
predicciones podemos hacer qué
proyecciones hay es muy difícil
responder taxativamente digamos a esa
pregunta pero de lo que se puede ver es
que habrá un final bastante disputado
bastante reñido hasta este momento las
encuestas demuestran un empate digamos
así en algunas aparece guillermo nació
en primer lugar en wordpress aparece
entre zarautz pero lo que se puede decir
en este momento y más allá de incluso
para no violar la vida de divulgación de
encuestas
es que lo más probable es que sea un
final muy reñido y que se defina por muy
pocos votos
para finalizar profesor el 24 de mayo el
presidente de lenin moreno entrega su
mandato al ganador del domingo como
quedar a su imagen después de la gestión
de la pandemia y una golpeada economía
lenin moreno es el presidente que más
baja aceptación o más baja calificación
ha tenido en el periodo democrático de
ecuador es decir desde el año 1979
no ha habido ningún presidente que tenga
una calificación tan baja sí y eso se
debe a varios factores uno es el propio
desgaste por la ruptura con rafael
correa
digamos quedó prácticamente sin partido
político sin un apoyo orgánico
el sí mismo y sus seguidores no sabían
cuántos diputados cuántos de
asambleístas contaban en el órgano
legislativo y luego el de la crisis
económica quedó del gobierno anterior y
por último la pandemia que lo afectó
pero que estará siempre siguiendo muy
débil muy débil y termina en esas
condiciones
así es profesora tengo que despedir por
el tiempo gracias por el suyo